I wouldn't do a serious just because
drats as a series would be really rough
under with the makeup and a few toe
but what I would like to do is honesty
and this is not my idea unsealing this
idea but James Gunn had the idea to do a
Drax mantis movie hole and that's what I
would be up for because there's just too
much fun down yeah well all right hold
on a Drax and mantas team up movie oh
hell yes you want to do it yet idea port
now it's just Marvel has their slot you
know that's not for the next five years
and they know how their story's gonna go
it's hard for them just to have an idea
for a film and say yeah we want to fit
that in here so I just didn't fit into
their schedule so should fight one
another from the honor of Lucian I got
some blasters unless you guys want to
use knives oh yes please use knives
[Laughter]
there should be no knifing one another
everybody knows who's in charge me yes
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my breakdown video for all
the guardians of the galaxy spin-off
movies that Drax here is talking about
as well as the other stuff that they've
announced so far Marvel does have big
plans for more space based movies during
Marvel phase four in phase five if
you're new to the channel we're doing
that movie ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what the next big
space-based character you want them to
introduces so first surfer Nova who do
you guys want
so we'll just break this down top-5
style starting with number five so as he
says James Gunn has pitched a couple
guardians of the galaxy spin-off movies
the Drax mantis movie that Dave Bautista
is talking about in this clip at the
beginning of this is just one of those
the main reason being is that before a
lot of the new Marvel phase 4 in phase 5
movies that they've talked about that
they're getting ready to do there just
weren't that many space based Marvel
movies with places for some of these
weirder guardians characters to show up
Peter quill is from Earth it's totally
believable that he could show up on
earth in a future Avengers movie just to
briefly pick them up and fly them
wherever their next battle is docking at
the newly created sword space
in a fury created at some point crude is
one of those characters that you could
put with almost any different team in
the Marvel Universe on earth anywhere
else and he would work really well just
as a great comedic addition and when
James Gunn was talking about this Drax
mantis spin-off they didn't have the
Disney Plus series yet which are
primarily created for stories that they
didn't have space for in the movie
release schedule like he says because
Marvel can only do three to four movies
per year if you count the Sony
spider-man movies usually it's three per
year but with the spider-man movies it
makes it four for the most part Disney
Plus is also for the stories that they
don't think have quite as much
box-office potential as Safer picks like
one division is a great example in the
Hawkeye series two really cool
characters that wouldn't necessarily be
as big of a box-office draw as say Thor
for you also again like six hours to
tell a story instead of two and a half
and some stories just do not fit in that
short theatrical runtime q Avengers end
game even though it was over three hours
long think about how much footage in
scenes they left on the cutting room
floor number four the main reason why
they don't have space in their release
schedule even though they're doing up to
four movies per year is because now they
have Deadpool 3 all the x-men characters
a ton of x-men characters and all the
Fantastic Four characters to deal with
that's in addition to them setting up
the idea of a new Avengers roster
introducing all these new solo
characters like shang-chi Nova Silver
Surfer Galactus so many huge characters
there's just only so much space that
they have and they've already announced
their schedule through 2022 and 2023
even though some of these Marvel phase 5
movies just have release dates they
haven't announced what they are they
just untitled Marvel movie although I
have done a couple Marvel phase 5 videos
about what those are based on what their
production schedule is so I'll link some
of those at the end of this as much as I
would be down for a Drax mantis Disney
Plus series the reason why Dave Bautista
says that they're not going to do that
it's just because from a practical
standpoint the process of putting on his
makeup is so torturous that he
physically would not be able to
withstand doing it for the duration of
time it would take to film all six
episodes and it takes a lot longer to
film the Disney Plus Series than it does
one of their big movies what would they
be about though the Drax mantis spin-off
what mostly Drax is still deal
with the loss of his family the
completion of his revenge arc with
Thanos which is now kind of complete
because that was initially the reason
why he joined the guardians team is
because he wanted to get revenge against
Thanos and they got it during avengers
endgame so his arc should be complete so
both he and mantas would presumably go
start a new life together because even
though they didn't really have a
romantic arc during the film's through
guardians to an Avengers infinity war
Avengers endgame they do form one of
Marvel's better odd couples the oddest
of couples but you'd have to imagine
them getting into a bunch of crazy
adventures créme ring themself from one
situation to the next because of the way
they interpret other people and social
situations so number three the other
guardians of the galaxy three spin-off
the James gonna spoken about earlier
were rocket and Groot spin-off he talked
about that when he was working on
guardians of the galaxy to so some of
those plans may have changed a little
bit because rocket is supposed to be one
of the main characters of guardians
three focusing on him in a ways the
previous movies happen you may have seen
James Gunn responding to a lot of people
on social media recently getting upset
with him thinking that he's going to
kill off rocket for the same reason that
they kill groot in the first movie and
then yondu in the second movie even
though we got another version of Groot
he is adamant that Groot died in the
first film and that this is kind of like
groots offspring technically groots
powers are a little bit different in the
comics he can regrow himself from a
single twig so if you're going by
comic-book rules it's the same Groot
but if you're going by what James Gunn
says baby Groot and then teenage Groot
are completely different versions of the
character part of the reason why people
think that he might kill rocket off is
that he'll complete his life's arc he'll
go from being this angry little trash
panda with a laundry list of issues
because of the terrible things that have
happened to him in his life and wind up
sacrificing himself selflessly to save
the other Guardians the same way that
group did in the first film the same way
that yondu did in the second film
remember the scene that rocket had with
yon dude during guardians to talking
about why he understood him why he's
such a crap bag to all of his friends
why you're so angry all the time because
I used to be exactly like you yondu
found inner peace through the course of
guardians to sacrificed himself to save
Peter quill his adopted son
they even both acknowledged it even
though this guy is your birth father
he's not
your real father I'm your real father
when characters get that sort of
self-actualization in completion of
their arc that's usually when people
kill them off same thing happened to
Iron Man in Black Widow in Avengers
endgame they sort of complete their
life's arc the path that I set us on so
even though the Black Widow twist was a
little more confusing the Black Widow
movie which is going to be set during
the past will provide some more context
for that but I'll talk about that when I
do more black widow videos the other
spin-off although technically I don't
consider it a spin up is Sylvester
Stallone implied that his guardians 3000
team might continue to show up again in
future space-based movies number 2 what
is going to happen to the guardians
roster after guardians of the galaxy 3
if James Gunn really is implying that at
least one of the team members will be
killed off remember he's killed off one
of the team members in every single
movie so they're probably going to do
another one in number three also a lot
of these guardians actors contracts are
gonna be up after Guardians 3 and some
of them will come back some of them will
not come back Chris Pratt has already
said many times that he wants to pull a
Chris Hemsworth Thor and keep coming
back for more Marvel movies as long as
they'll have him so he's probably
sticking around long term if they're
talking about doing Drax and mantas
spin-offs it sounds like they were
originally going to leave the team
anyway that leaves a lot of open spaces
for new characters so I think Thor would
be amazing if he hung out with him after
Thor for love and thunder for some real
ass guardians of the galaxy beta ray
bill would be an amazing long-term
addition to the team and obviously we're
just heading into Marvel phase 4 and
Marvel phase 5 there's gonna be a bunch
more space based characters debuting
during those movies including x-men
characters who would all be great on a
new guardians roster so there'll be a
lot of other new characters that we
haven't met yet like Nova is a good
example he would be cool on a Guardians
team but number one as for Thor actually
coming back during guardians of the
galaxy 3 Chris Pratt was actually just
talking about this recently in an
interview here's a clip of that 9
Guardians 3 how do you know that Thor's
on guardians 3 we haven't shot it yet he
might be in for guardians 3 you know we
don't know there's no definitive yes or
no on that
oh my Jake but we'll have to wait and
see you'll just have to wait and see
it's this they've got you just Chris
Pratt's trying to be funny about it but
it sounds like he isn't
flying Thor's supposed to have a cameo
during guardians three if it's not gonna
be a really big role they just have to
sign Chris Hemsworth to a new contract
so they haven't completely worked out
all the red tape yet but that is the
idea the Thor would cameo everyone let
me know in the comments what kind of
guardians of the galaxy spin-offs do you
want to see after guardians 3 and what
do you want them to do with Thor after
Thor for love and thunder if he's not
gonna stay on earth really hoping for
that Thor Silver Surfer crossover you
could also do a Guardians Silver Surfer
crossover - but I'm mostly expecting
guardians 3 to introduce Adam warlock
I'll name a new giveaway winner when I
post my next Marvel video leave all your
requests in the comments below
everyone click here for that new
Avengers infinity saga deleted scenes of
Thor in one of Iron Man becoming Doctor
Strange and click here for my new Thor
for Christian Bale video thank you so
much for watching everyone stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you